look at me the eyes John hey what's
going on everybody four first we feast
I'm Sean Evans coming at you from Bali
kitchen in the East Village where I'm
joined by Bryan Emanuel aka rich chigga
you known from singles like blow like
that and dad stick he has a new one with
21 sevens called crisis out now it's a
heater but before the turtleneck and
fanny pack swag took the internet by
storm Bryan was just a kid growing up in
the capital city of Jakarta and that's
why we're here to get a crash course in
Indonesian cuisine and Brian when I say
Indonesian cuisine
what's lighting up your brain what are
you thinking about right now I'm
thinking of you know waking up in the
morning smelling the cooking from you
know my mom she just cooks every day my
grandma sometimes cooks and they would
just cook a bunch of like monado food
cuz my mom's from there and you know
it's like a lot of spicy stuff a lot of
a lot of pork a lot of you know chicken
a lot of vegetables and just like a lot
of spices for sure yeah and then too you
know as someone who's been on the road
now is it difficult to find Indonesian
food definitely I've actually never had
Indonesian food that I'm in America so
there's like my first time I'm very
excited honestly I just miss the instant
noodles in Indonesia there's this thing
called like endo means and they're like
amazing and literally at one point on
eBay it became like the number-one like
Christmas present because like Americans
just love it so much yeah it's amazing
you need to try it
alright well today we're gonna have some
of the most classic
recognizable Indonesian dishes around to
see if they stack up to rich Chika's
high bar alright first things first you
know we had to start with rendang it's a
coconut based slow cook stew served with
vegetables 7-ball and jasmine rice
typically served with spicy beef yes and
you haven't had Indonesian food and so
long this gets plopped down in front of
you yeah it smells just like the real
one so
very excited to do this so basically in
Indonesia we never use like the fork
like we never put the book on the right
hand and just like eat it like that so
it's always on the left hand and we do
spilling is always just like the main
pain
the fork is basically just to like it's
kind of like a support system and you
know you like take it you know take take
some beef right here and then you kind
of like get some on the spoon and yeah
I'm ready when you are
cheers my man Cheers mmm Wow scratching
that itch that you've been what that
scratch for a while that is so good man
that's amazing and then you know
sometimes it's kind of called a hurry
how would you describe the dish how does
it fit into Indonesian culture in
Indonesia we have this thing called a
pate which is basically this it's the
Indonesian way of saying curry this is
not exactly it sorry now is from bow
down and basically fly down food is
known for like being super greasy and
like super like big you know having it
like a super big portion and you just
get it when you're like just hungry as
hell and you don't care about your
health the basic way yeah and then too
I think that we should talk about but I
want to bust it out boom oh here we have
Sam ball hmm now as somebody who's in
the hot sauce game I hear about this all
the time that's basically like an
accompanying sauce like a salsa and some
of them are quite hot very hot is this
something that you use often how hot do
you go talk to me about this it's kind
of like salsa but it's also kind of like
Kobe barbecue sauce at the same time and
it varies like like a lot and you know
some are like a lot spicier than the
other and with our done usually I never
I've never tried something over there no
i don't i will so don't know what kind
of some of all this is so I'm just gonna
I'm down to try some too with you
so let's go there let's get it this
let's cross that one and then two I mean
some of these are crazy hot I'm just
going in blind on this one this so
basically usually like the rule of thumb
is like when it's super red it's usually
not that hot I feel like this has been a
little Americanized usually you would be
able to taste like the flavor of the
chili more but I've never tried this one
actually I don't know but this one I
heard that because we got a little bit
of some Bo on the middle so I don't know
what cut this one looks a little more
spicy let's try this one mmm that's more
yeah so this one right here this is kind
of like this is like the Bali kind of
humble like you you find these kind of
like a lot more in Balinese food and I
don't know what it is I don't know what
they put in there but definitely it's
like it tastes like jelly yeah it's a
little earthier you know that feels a
little more grown from the dirt growing
from red soil um I actually have no idea
maybe but yeah definitely reminds me of
Bali for sure up next nasi grand yes sir
Indonesian style fried rice with eggs
sweet soy sauce fresh pickled garlic
crackers served with chicken or tofu and
then as I understand this is the
national dish of Indonesia yeah what can
you tell me about growing up with this
it's like a big breakfast thing in
Indonesia I feel like how's he gonna
staple a classic yeah you know you and
your friends have it like for you and
when you guys are like drop the [ __ ]
it's also like a thing that your parents
just you know sometimes make you in the
morning when they when they're trying to
be nice to you you know my dad is like a
big like rice dude that's a big rice but
um he's like yo do you wanna like have
you had lunch
like yeah I have like a burger or
something and he's like but you know
like there was no rice like you didn't
basically you didn't eat yeah it's not
you doesn't have rice it's not yeah yeah
it's it's that's that's so important it
is so there's like different types of
Nazi coding in Indonesia
this one I think we're having with
chicken and there would be some with
like goat meat and this kind of
seasoning that they would use is kind of
more like in Middle Eastern but this
this tastes like the normal this is the
classic is the class how funky does it
get
have you ever seen them get real funky
with it so NASA garden just means fried
rice and the others thing called nothing
go to Gila and geo that means crazy so
it's like just crazy fried rice and they
just like slice up hotdogs and Padres
yeah and they think it's [ __ ] crazy
speaking of hot dogs you know it should
be it shouldn't be understated how good
your food tweets are is it still the
best way to ether someone by calling
them a hot dog and that's still the
worst insult you know like if you're
just walking around the streets of New
York I don't know like or like a you
know homeless dude comes up to you and
you know calls you names or whatever
you're just like yeah it's a [ __ ]
homeless guy right but then you know the
homeless guy comes up to you and he's
like you're a [ __ ] hot dog you like
think about that for a while it's true
you know like am i hot dogs like am I
even [ __ ] human [ __ ] that
alright so up next we have satay
Makassar how'd I do on that one pretty
good you know how are my pronunciations
I'm always I'm always self-conscious
about my disgusting Mid Western drawl
you know iterate I'm feeling Indonesian
it has some similarities with Spanish
where you just kind of like kind of roll
the arse and then so it's like South Bay
I'm episode even so this one is a
grilled chicken skewer you served with
coconut rice cake salad spicy mango
pickle yes sir are you familiar with
this one is this one new to you where we
are
I've tried satay before so some Makassar
is like a it's a region in Indonesian so
this is like one of those things where
it's like a different in another region
so this is like a second new little
thing for me
in every culture you'll find some sort
of skewered dish what does satay is
place in Indonesia you have it at night
mostly you're like walking in the
streets there would be like people
walking like a cart very much a street
food yeah it's definitely a street food
and yeah that's what you kind of like
smell the charcoal a little bit on it
[Music]
okay oh very fresh that's the way to do
it little mango mmm
you have the chicken and you really do
get a real heavy charcoal element yeah
you are it definitely you can tell that
the street food yeah it reminds me of
like being a kid going back to like my
dad's hometown to visit our grandparents
every time I smell like shark bull like
got snow to think of it and this is
bringing me back we're really bringing
you back not to cry right now Shawn you
about to make me cry
on TV it's not going on TV
so let's bring it all home rich chicka
because you know you said you haven't
had Indonesian food in so long Polly
kitchen here one of the only Indonesian
restaurants in New York City does it
stack up how does it feel
yeah it feels like that homes it feels
like it definitely you know I feel like
Americans would love this and it's like
it's definitely like a good you don't
have like of you if you want to know
like what Indonesian food is like this
is like the place to go there you go and
then because it's someone on the road
you know you probably can't get the food
that you've been craving this whole time
so let the Indonesian food wave catch
like a wildfire if you're in New York
City the place to go Bali Kitchen rich
chicka you're already not always gonna
be here you know holding it down he's
just got a corner table just come and
say what's not take a selfie this single
is called crisis and then of course we
have the Asian tour on deck in December
first we feast you already know
thanks for checking in we'll see you
next time internet Thank You Shaun Evans